no burying the lede here I tried making
a 3d game in JavaScript using mostly
code from previous tutorials and ended
up with not too bad of a little game
after a few hours I don't like to do
work I don't have to so the goal here
was to write as little new code as
possible we'll walk through all the
changes made but there aren't that many
we reuse as much as possible from
previous tutorials and projects we
already made a bunch of stuff like we
made those boards a few months ago
simple individual behaviors creating
complicated group behavior and we've
done a whole series on 3d world
generation so the plan let's mash
together the Boyd's and the planet
generation stuff and like add some
spaceships and shooting and stuff so
first things first we'll clone the last
tutorial into a new folder and we'll
make some small changes like we'll go
modify the name first and that gets us
like 90% of the way there now I kind of
had a rough plan here like really rough
the first thing we need to do is add a
spaceship flying around currently
movement is controlled by the camera
code this is the FPS controls whose job
it is is to watch for keyboard commands
and move the camera left/right up/down
etc we'll make a few simple
modifications beginning with copy
pasting it as ship controls and then
we'll look at the on key handlers and
change them a bit to handle a few more
inputs like rockets firing and things
like that next we need to look at the
update function this is where the
transform is applied and for ship we
need to change this to be able to do yaw
pitch and roll this is what this block
of code here does it looks at what keys
are pressed and kind of pieces together
the transform and obviously here is
where we fire the Rockets to go faster
or not lastly we want the camera to
follow a ship in sort of a delayed way
like it's chasing the ship so we offset
it behind the ship and interpolate
towards the same heading once we do that
bam cube flying through space I guess we
could make this a board game and call it
done now let's actually load a better
model so we'll head over to sketchfab
and we can get a whole bunch of decent
quality free stuff on here there's a lot
of options for spaceships once we have
one downloaded will add some loading
code here in main j/s that loads the
x-wing model and then creates the main
player and ship controls all
most right and kind of huge and not
facing the right way we need to scale
and rotate it to face the way we want
now through trial and error having it
seems to look pretty decent and we got
ourselves a ship this one is pretty
sweet too not clear why I didn't choose
this the first time but maybe someone
else can try it anyway we got our ship
let's go add some more ships first we
need to merge in all that void code
which is a simple copy/paste job but if
you remember those ships look like crap
since I made them so let's fix that
back in sketchfab there's some great
options here Tie Fighters and Star
Destroyers and it's the same deal in the
code we need to load the gltf and figure
out a magic scaling that looks good
scaling it down to about one twentieth
the size looks about right so I'll roll
with that
then we need to create a material and
load the textures and then go down to
create all the enemy ships here so in
create enemy ships we just want to do a
couple things we want to load the Star
Destroyer model and then make it
appropriately big then we want to go and
create like a hundred or so of these
enemy fighters which is what we do in
this loop you can see here that we
cloned loaded TIE fighter model a bunch
of times at this point you kind of have
something going a ship that flies around
and some enemy ships that really do
nothing but it's it's getting there
in agent jeaious will modify the enemy
ship so the only fire on the player so
they see you around they'll take a shot
at you then we'll out a way for you to
fire so back in the player entity class
we add this fire method that creates a
blaster particle and fires it off since
this is an x-wing and those fire of all
four wings will create four offsets up
here and then rotate between them using
this offset index now when we go to fire
tbp you fires at all four wings now we
need things to die so in the blaster J's
code we'll look at each blaster shot
from everyone and get the list of all
potential candidates in the area and do
race fear intersection tests this isn't
the most robust code but it works and we
just call take damage on whoever we hit
first take damage does what the name
implies it applies a bunch of damage if
your health drops below zero create an
explosion at this spot and hide the
model job done the player can also take
damage although we let you take a few
more hits but
display an explosion each time now we
can blast away and blow up some ships
which is pretty cool last thing we want
a cool hug that's sci-fi looking with
lots of numbers and [ __ ] so I googled
that and got a whole bunch of super cool
ideas like this here is awesome I'd love
to add this but it's a lot of work and I
don't feel like it so let's make
something simple one of the cool things
about working in JavaScript is that I
can make the UI in HTML and just overlay
it on the screen so in create game GUI
and main dodge yes we'll create a few
divs and you can see the CSS here is
pretty simple we're just making a few
rounded boxes with borders and the one
thing to call out here is this mix blend
mode screen line here which can pause
this the div over the canvas using
Photoshop screen blend mode anyway a few
divs and some text and anenome died we
just update the text and voila
there's a kill counter in the corner one
last thing can't resist let's head over
to this Star Wars intro creator and make
ourselves some intro text and there you
go we've got a sweet intro for our game
I'll just kind of run it a bit faster
and blow through it here but that's
about it it didn't take much to add some
quick gameplay mechanics to our previous
code to get something decent up and
running just to cut flowers really
source code is all available on github
so fork it and go ahead and tweak it or
add to it or do whatever you want with
it
I don't really care make sure to hit
like and subscribe and see you next time
Cheers